maurice lemoine bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors on attend à lundi sous
haute tension à cuba quoi peut-on
s'attendre on sent bien que le bras de
fer se durcit entre l'opposition et le
gouvernement
oui je bras de fer se durcit pour les
retours d'ailleurs content et très bien
d'exprimer à la fin de votre reportage
passionnant c'est à dire que que tout
ceci se déroule dans un contexte qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qui serait la
défense de la démocratie dans nos pays
dans la mesure où cuba et la victime
d'une agression des états unis je dis
pas ça pour réciter un espèce de mantra
qui exonérerait à cuba de toute
responsabilité dans la crise économique
et sociale qui est réel qui a provoqué
les manifestations du 11 juillet dernier
tout simplement parce que dans un
contexte de pandémie la principale
activité économique du pays qui génère 7
% du pib c'est à dire le tourisme s'est
effondré et donc la société cubaine il
ya un malaise il ya un malaise social il
ya des pénuries vous l'avez mentionné
est donc tout à fait légitime en juillet
dernier des manifestants sont descendus
dans la rue au prix de nous avons faim
on n'en peut plus mais évidemment assez
à ces manifestants pacifiques légitime
quiconque on peut parfaitement
comprendre s'ajoute ce qu'il faut
appeler l'agression des états unis
puisque ces manifestations légitimes
sont instrumentalisées par une partie de
l'opposition qui est effectivement
dépend directement des états unis
puisqu'il faut le il faut le rappeler en
2001 la nouvelle fondation pour la
démocratie la led qui a été créée en
1983 par ronald reagan a fourni cinq
millions de dollars à des coupes de
combat appelé de déstabilisation cubains
dont le fameux mouvement sans les hydro
et que le le département d'état a prévue
pour 2022 le même budget que celui de
bill 21 c'est à dire 20 millions de
dollars pour des programmes de vip
destinées de démocratie destiné à cuba
c'est à dire qu'il ya très clairement
cette crise sociale s'inscrit dans
notation des états unis pour un
changement de régime
une date choisie celle du 15 novembre on
l'a dit eux que 7,7 cette mobilisation a
lieu sous fond sur fond de crise
sanitaire on sait que demain justement
les écoles doivent heures et ouvrir
après des mois notamment de fermeture le
tourisme qui doit aussi reprendre vous
parlais tout à l'heure du secteur
touristique qui est justement un des
secteurs qui apporte le plus d'argent à
cuba et en même temps les états unis
maintiennent leur embargo sur le sur
l'île non seulement ils lemagnen mes
lauriers quand ils l'ont renforcé
puisqu'il faut l'y faut il faut rappeler
que le président donald trump a adopté
deux cent quarante trois mesures pour
renforcer le le siège visant à asphyxier
l'économie d'eau l'île dont 55 mesurant
pas en pleine pandémie et on pourrait
dire malheureusement le président byden
n'est absolument pas revenu sur ces
mesures donc effectivement l'économie
cubaine cuba est en difficulté il faut
il faut rappeler évidemment qu en juin
dernier comme tous les ans l'assemblée
générale des nations unies et à trois
exceptions près a condamné l'embargo des
états unis contre cuba et je rajouterais
que en août de cette année ou 2021
quatre experts de l'onu
ont condamné les sanctions unilatérales
en déclarant là je vous cite j'ai devant
moi la citation exacte de ces quatre
experts de l'onu d activité essentielle
au développement de chaque pays souffre
lorsque des sanctions unilatérales sont
imposés les habitants des pays ciblés
comme le venezuela cuba la syrie et
l'iran sombrer dans la pauvreté parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas obtenir des
services essentiels comme l'électricité
le logement l'eau le gaz et le carburant
sans parler des médicaments et la
nourriture est là pour le coup avec
celle des experts de l'onu tout est dit
en réalité quel pays de la région
pourraient aujourd'hui à apporter
le raid à cuba
les pays de la région c'était évidemment
les pays membres de ce qu'on appelle la
halle balladur as polisarienne pour les
peuples de notre amérique qui sont eux
mêmes d'ailleurs cités par le
département d'état des états unis c'est
à dire le venezuela et le venezuela et
le nicaragua vous savez que john bolton
l'ancien conseillait la défense
nationale de trump avait déclaré ces
trois pays la troïka delà de la tyrannie
et puis un certain nombre de pays comme
le mexique demande le napa des 500
contre contre cuba du par ailleurs hors
continent latino-américain il a certain
nombre de pays qui sont sans doute
excédé par le lilas terra liste des
états unis je pense à la silice penche à
la chine qu'il ya note robert toupin
soit le point diplomatique se prononce
contre cette politique alors les
dernières manifestations avaient été
particulièrement violente est ce que on
peut imaginer des scènes similaires
demain coulé en ce qui concerne la
violence des manifestations qu'ils ont
été vues elles ont été sérieuses y
compris la répression des manifestations
a fait a fait un mort et des dizaines de
blessés d aider des gens passionnés qui
ont certains sont encore en prison mais
là encore je pense qu'il faut
relativiser c'est à dire que un mort
lors d'une manifestation au cul brèche
rappelle qu'en et dernière grande
manifestation en bolivie ont fait 34
morts en équateur et ont fait 11 morts
au chili elles ont fait 27 morts en
haïti 77 morts en colombie 80 ans vous
valez quand en réalité même si on peut
déplorer la répression quel que soit
dans quelque pays que ce soit les
cubains ne sont pas les plus mal lotis
merci beaucoup en tout cas maurice
lemoine d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine